so today I thought we could talk about
this paper that recently came out called
AI safety grid world's which is an
indeed mind it's an example of something
that you see quite often in science a
sort of a shared data set or a shared
environment or a shared problem if you
imagine I don't know you've got Facebook
comes up with some image classification
algorithm and they can publish a paper
that says we've designed this algorithm
and we've trained it on our 11 billion
photos and it works really well and then
you know Google says oh no our algorithm
actually works better and we've trained
it on all of our google photos and its
classification rate is higher or
something you're not really doing
science there because they're trained on
completely different datasets they're
tested on different datasets so what you
need is a large high-quality shared data
set then everybody can run their stuff
on so that you're actually comparing
like with like so people use imagenet
for that right now
reinforcement learning algorithms or
agents don't use datasets exactly they
have an environment they generate data
while interacting with that environment
and that's what they learn from so the
thing you share is the environment when
deepmind did their dqn staff a while ago
playing atari games they released all of
those games with any modifications that
they'd made to make them interface with
the network's properly and the whole
software package so that if anybody else
wanted to have a go and see if they
could get higher scores they had all the
same stuff and up until now there hasn't
been anything like that for AI safety so
the paper is actually just laying out
what they are there's kind of a problem
in AI safety in that you're trying to
build architectures which will be safe
even with systems which are more
powerful than the ones that we currently
have so you've got this kind of thing
like we're talking about for example
this robot that makes you a cup of tea
and running over the baby and all of
this stuff we don't actually have a
general-purpose robot like that right
now that you could give an order to go
and make your cup of tea and would have
all the necessary understanding of the
world and so on for all of that stuff to
even apply it's speculation on the other
hand when we were talking about
cooperative inverse reinforcement
learning that paper all takes place in
this extremely simplified
version in which all of the agents can
be sort of expressed as simple
mathematical expressions that's kind of
too simple to be to learn things about
actual machine learning applications and
the other examples are too complicated
and what we need is examples of the type
of problems which can be tackled by
current machine learning systems current
reinforcement learning agents but which
exhibit the important characteristics
that we need for safety so what this
paper does is it lays out a bunch of
grid worlds they're very popular in
reinforcement learning because they're
complicated enough to be interesting but
simple enough to be actually tractable
you have a world that's sort of just
laid out in a grid hang on let me find
an example here a bit like computer game
scenarios Mario you know being right
right but leaves are simpler than that
more like snake or life Conway's life
right yeah yeah very very similar so the
thing is laid out on a grid the the
world is quite small and the way that
the agent interacts with the world is
very simple they just move around it
basically all they do is they say
left-right up-down the example we were
using before and we were talking about
reinforcement learning we use pac-man
like pac-man doesn't do anything except
move around
he's got walls he can't moved through
he's got like pills you pick up they
give you points
are they pill no which things are the
pills in which they right yeah yeah the
dots and the point is that all of your
engagement with it like when you go over
one of the power pills you pick it up
automatically when you go over a ghost
when you're powered up you destroy it
automatically you don't have to do
anything apart for a move and the entire
environment is based on that the actions
result in points for you and they also
result in changes to the environment
like once you roll over a dot you pick
it up and it's not there anymore you've
changed the world that's the kind of
thing we're dealing with here so the
idea is they've set up these
environments and they've specified them
precisely and they've also put the whole
thing on github which is really nice so
that's why that's why I wanted to draw
people's attention to this because
everyone who
who thinks that they've solved one of
these problems they reckon oh yeah all
you have to do is this here is like a
standardized thing and if you can make a
thing that does it and does it properly
and publish it that's a great result you
know so I would I would recommend
everyone who thinks that they have a
solution or an approach that they think
is promising have a go try implementing
it you know see what happens there are
eight of them specified in this paper
and so four of them are specification
problems they're situations in which
your reward function is misspecified for
example like we talked about the
previous video if you give the thing the
reward function that only talks about
getting you a cup of tea and there's
something in the way like a bars it's
going to knock over you didn't say that
you cared about the bars it's not in the
reward function but it is in what you
care about it's in your performance
evaluation function for this machine so
anytime that those two are different
then you've got a misspecified reward
function and that can cause various
different problems the other ones are
robustness problems which is a different
class of safety problem they're just
situations in which AI systems as
they're currently designed often break
so for example distributional shift is
what happens when the environment that
the agent is in is different in an
important way from the environment it
was trained in so in this example you
have to navigate through this room with
some lava and they train it in one room
and then they test it in a room where
the lava is in a slightly different
place so if you've just learned a path
then you're gonna just hit the lava
immediately this happens all the time in
machine learning anytime where the
system is faced with a situation which
is different from what it was trained
for current AI systems are really bad at
spotting that they're in a new situation
and adjusting their confidence levels or
asking for help or anything
usually they apply whatever rules
they've learned straightforwardly
to this different situation and screw up
so that's a that causes safety issues so
that's an example here or things like
safe exploration it's a problem where
you have certain safety parameters that
the system the train system has to stick
to like so you're training a
self-driving car a lot of the behavior
that you're training in is safe behavior
but then you also need
the system to obey those safety rules
while you're training it right like so
generally like if you're doing
self-driving cars you don't just put the
car on the road and tell it to learn how
to drive specifically because we don't
have algorithms that can explore the
space of possibilities in a safe way
that they're that they don't that they
can learn how to behave in the
environment without ever actually doing
any of the things that they're not
supposed to do usually with these kinds
of systems they have to do it and then
get the negative reward and then maybe
do it like a hundred thousand more times
to really cement that that's what
happens like a child learning yeah but
kids are better at this
then how current machine learning
systems are they just they use data way
more efficiently this is a paper talking
about a set of worlds if you like people
doing things in those worlds yeah so in
this paper they do establish baselines
basically they say here's what happens
if we take some of our best current
reinforcement learning agent you know
algorithms or designs or architectures
they use rainbow and A to C and they run
them on these on these problems and they
have kind of graphs of how they do and
generally it's not good on the Left they
have the reward function how well the
agent does according to its own reward
function and on the right there they
have the actual safety performance
usually in reinforcement learning you
have a reward function which is what
determines the reward that the agent
gets and that's what the agent is trying
to maximize in this case they have the
reward function and they also have a
safety performance function which is a
separate function which the agent
doesn't get to see and that's the thing
that we're actually evaluating so if you
look at something like the boat race as
the system operates its learning and it
gets better and better at getting more
and more reward but worse at actually
doing laps of the track and it's the
same with pretty much all of these the
current systems if you just apply them
in their default way they disable their
off switches they move the box in a way
that they can't move it back they behave
differently if their supervisor is there
or if then supervisor isn't there they
fairly reliably do
wrong thing it's a nice easy baseline to
beat because they're just showing the
standard algorithms applied to these
problems in the standard way behave
unsafely
Wix code is an IDE or integrated
development environment that allows you
to manage your data and create web apps
with advanced functionality I've been
put together this computer for our
website and if you go up to code here
turn on and developer tools you can see
how we get the site structure on the
left hand side and then all of the
components start to show their tags next
to the text here what's really nice if
you go over to the Wix code resources
you can find down here there's a cheat
sheet so if I want to find out the tag
for location for instance if I could
type I type in location up comes that or
perhaps I want to perform a fetch I can
find all the details here what's
powerful about Wix code is it's
integrated into Wix so you can put
together the website using all the Wix
tools and the layouts and the templates
that they provide and then also have
access to all those backend functions so
click on the link in the description or
go to Wix calm to get started on your
website today they go right yeah so the
equivalent one for the stop button
problem is the first one in the paper
actually this safe interrupt ability